hello everybody violin is I rely well I
will I will aid hey guys hahaha what are
you really you're not gonna acknowledge
anything come on no oh god no the
quality level was just going so far down
we can't do this cars out does it ever
not know we are high quality
entertainers don't you know we have a
certain standard that we need to adhere
to at all times
what's probably picking on ultimate what
I hear something big walking around I
don't hear something big but I hears
something walking well where this flag
come from I played it that's we claimed
this area
oh well good it yeah well I hear
something - yeah wait a minute
um Dover DE where I don't know I hear
dogs a dino over there
no don't go near it probably dangerous
seriously you know what adaiah what do I
do with my or alright okay what I and
put it in there oh yeah I'll put it in
there yeah
do it okay I put newly not my raw stone
though I got 32 raw stone what do I do
with it
um stone hang on - okay now what do I
craft I can craft a bed oh I don't have
any iron we need iron ore we need to
cross the furnace first okay furnace
you're making the furnace I can make it
alright you can make it I'll set it down
somewhere okay I will alright I'm
actually I'm actually excited were
actually making progress is crazy we
never do this where do I set it oh right
right by the table right yeah all right
what did your except the tribe invite
yeah well they're a part of the tribe
show up so I refreshed it now a part of
the douche Nuggets
I'm with good news Nuggets I'm glad yeah
that's is that the name of the thing
yeah I think so
okay good douche Nuggets all the way
douche Nuggets for life oh hey listen
dinosaur friends here isn't oh don't you
dare you douche I will slap the [ __ ] out
of you or the kool-aid yes I'd like you
just flopping around that's the walking
sounds like flopping that's their big
giant Dino dick that's flopping flopping
like aa drag
one you know that a lot to carry back
then you know so pain wait did they even
have you know I I mean it's a weird
question asked but I mean how else would
they have made it well they're not
mammals so I mean well I mean actually
that's the fact not all mammals are not
all their dicks aren't exclusive to
mammals what I've tried is exactly I
should shut up right now shouldn't like
I should not be talking this is
approaching the level of life at the
time you censor yourself in Minecraft
that wasn't that bad people still don't
know what I said but it was that bad
well I mean it was pretty bad
no it wasn't it wasn't like a racial
slur ring no no it wasn't bad people
thought it well I was like I was like
doing on a racial rant like Kramer from
that one show that I never watched
Seinfeld no no no no it wasn't like that
no they don't races there was no it
wasn't offending to a particular person
or type it was just it was just bad the
Contra Blues is bad I should just shut
up but no I'm gonna press forward
because that's how I am that's what I do
that's who I be okay what do I do with
this damn furnace um take some of the
ores out of the crafting table that have
been identified and put them in the
furnace with wood why does the inventory
for the front for the crafting table
keep disappearing okay take the iron put
it in the thing pull it into my thing
get the rock card iron in the thing and
have funnel turn babies what that those
magnesium will do I don't know I don't
know what there's like ten ores I don't
know what half of them I thought you
were an expert
come on expert why aren't you an expert
cuz I've played it that much why not uh
cuz I'm not started play like a day and
a half ago
I'm sorry I need a room having baby I've
only gotten two episodes posted even
with well by now you would have had four
so you just lied to all your whole
audience and they have no idea what's
going on I mean I would have had four
you would have four by the time this
one's poses like the fifth episode if
you're gonna probably more than that you
gotta I've got two series to post ahead
of this one unless I post them all
simultaneously really gonna give me back
stress all this weight oh is that what
is mustard what you think we could kill
it
no don't kill it I don't want to die I
go so far my keys my green bars all the
way down I don't know what to be wait
there's no wood in the firs it's not
even cooking you didn't tell me I needed
to place the forest is a forest with
some wood why would I know that I need
to put get out poop wood in the first do
I need plant the furnace bird well I
mean it's like maybe on man I gotta
always give me the first already you
used it to cook the charcoal you don't
even know that that was me who else
would've been maybe dinosaur gob and poo
in the ferns I don't know I don't
remember these things it would like Sega
Sports decided it wanted to cook some
wood you don't know maybe it was like
the Walter White of dinosaurs as he was
like what's our white yeah from Breaking
Bad he was like Josie we got a cook I
have a danger you know now we've got a
bunch of like drug-dealing dinosaurs out
here cooking up their junk in a furnace
they're not cooking their junk they're
dyno dogs don't need to because that
kind of junk
will their druggie Joe okay I'm not even
following your logic anymore you don't
make any sense Wade oh I don't think
this partnership of the douche Nuggets
gonna work the fellowship of a Koosh
Nuggets is breaking apart oh oh okay
fine then oh don't hit me please all
right uh yeah where you have the same
train of thought it's true though
when we're insulting each other we still
make progress we were both usually get
more done when we're insulting each
other we should its own each other more
often
we really should or we should
frantically yell about losing control of
the douche Nuggets well now I don't know
what to say I mean I can't just force
the insult now if they ever come
naturally we need to do something stupid
first I could go attack that dinosaur
you're not gonna do that I know you're
not why not we could take it we've got
too much to risk at this point we could
never do it that's true I mean our stuff
would stay here but we'd be lost forever
by the way huh you dude I looked up at
the top right yeah you can see your
coordinates are like 45 negative 145 or
something like that okay so you can use
that there's like a jeep to find your
way back I didn't listen to a word you
said
do you know how coordinates work maybe
they're like numbers yes they are like
numbers okay um there's an X and there's
a while Ostia and okay there's a blood
first number okay Falls number gotcha
two numbers got it I'm with it
and one number can go up or down
okay you know what direction you're
driving do I don't know um number up
good number up good yes got it number up
yes number up good yeah so I do it
so you yes good yeah I feel like I just
lost praise Oh Oh number I'm good
Oh how does that help us live what do we
do now
what do we do with our new number of
good knowledge we god I feel so sweet
try not to die with it oh I feel so
smart
oh yeah so does charcoal burn this also
no charcoals used for other things that
only the wood logs will burn ah by the
way there was no gold or silver or in
here right none of that
um we need to take some of these ores
out before we put new ores in because
there's only limited space I think maybe
not maybe they'll just keep making new
space I don't know it doesn't seem to be
doing that but now okay yeah we should
probably all take out the iron ingots
okay I put more iron in there so there
will be more iron ingots being made okay
I'll I'll just take out all the ingots
and for now we'll dues oh my god what
are we doing are we cooperating yes oh
my god we'll never get anything done it
this really Walton God you smell like a
horseradish condoms
goddamn sound disgusting cuz I like you
don't want Harry Potter they had amazing
I'm what are you going to follow my
logic for my lunch there was like Harry
Potter there was the jelly beans that
were any flavor yeah are there like
condoms in Harry Potter world that are
like any flavor to you gotta imagine
they put magic into everything so there
had to be some magic sex toys if you
know what I mean right just like an
enhancer your size and shape to whatever
hahaha you oh man they no not even magic
could possibly do that that's the
technologies like he is heat-seeking to
the bottoms that what you said yeah yes
please tell me they're heat-seeking
condoms of the world Harry Potter just
take off and go for whatever they will
walk with me that sounds horrible for
women or men god that is the most
disturbing thing hit themselves always
feel good like okay I guess oh oh I
don't well okay oh how even in the
Wizarding World does that work I mean
you got to think at some level at some
primal level it's got to be all the same
but there were those weirdos that took
it to a level it didn't need to be took
you mean us oh yes executive what we're
doing right now that thing that's
happening right now that those weirdos
yeah you know what I mean gonna bail on
us awesome the middle of a like Avada
Kedavra
what you want to do yeah don't come near
me with that Ivana Kadamba Oh what about
a condom it's dead oh yeah my
horseradish guy yeah yeah good it was
heat-seeking and already accomplished
its mission you know what's weird is
that you know how they have moving
pictures in like magazines like porno
magazines in the Wizarding World must
have been amazing you gotta admit
look out at the base level that was
pretty incredible
but like someone's petronas was just
like a naked person what if those
petronas was just a dildo and they shot
her take my milky ghostly dildo
on a grid put that away oh my god
Hagrid didn't just have a wand under
that umbrella you know what I mean okay
never mind
we should move on we have totally
scarred everyone who like Harry we
should move this conversation derailed
somewhere wonderful but also horrible
anyway I've got some ingots what should
I do with them okay so six ingots and
like I forget how many would you can
make a bed one bed would it apply to
both of us sir no we're going to make
our own beds here um so I've got an idea
Oh God I will make us a house okay
I like it oh I need to make a lot of
planks so I'm gonna be standing here for
a while doing nothing fun to watch okay
got it
so what you usually do right honey this
is I got the occasional one-two punch of
condom jokes condom jokes wait who-who
are you punching with these condoms uh
anyone with my heat-seeking missile
powers Oh heat-seeking horseradish
condoms that with punches oh maybe
they're heat-seeking condoms but they
have those little boxing gloves on the
end otherwise you gonna crack and
they're just like boi-yoi-yoing by bad
the wrong spot that one Mike can someone
draw that draws up a schematic of that
we will sell these on the internet make
millions Millions
keep rambling like lucious [ __ ]
horseradish condom punching dildo
plushies yeah everyone who buy one don't
be so cute I love a little smiley face
on the end of them tail but actually
what I would do I would want ten of them
everyone would want them these are
genius ideas people but they're ours you
can't have a something unless you pick
17:19 less you pay seventy seventy
payments of $70.99 for your dildo condom
horseradish plushie with a smiley face
boxing glove on the end of it you can't
have it someone make that happen please
dear god someone may thud there's got to
be
went out there who's got huh someone has
the wherewithal and the total insanity
to do that we're gonna drive them out of
business or or their business will be
made exactly they could be so successful
it will be the only market for
horseradish punching bucks and smiling
glove condoms exactly oh my god why
didn't we think of this before
I don't know Oh probably because in here
come in the warp disturbed part of our
brains that whenever our two brains
connect it's like the worst ideas
possible come out who would love it okay
anyway uh what am I even doing I know
you're supposed to be making we need 12
iron ingots uh-huh and whatever it takes
to make a bed okay I can make one bed if
I just get a little more wood that's
that's what I can do I will do that for
you for the love of our douche Nuggets I
will do that oh good
these trees around the camp don't have
much more wood what is that glowing in
the distance yes I've got the planks for
a house wait did you see that there was
a light in the distance we have not been
focusing on the game like at all
no that's Dartmouth powers you can build
oh okay is that what they got over there
probably okay that makes sense and I'm
just gonna gather up quite a bit more
wood we need a little build it all house
and we could build a better one later if
we wanted I'm okay with that
if we even build a house I would be
shocked well I just built one so
everyone is shocked that we have the
mental capacity to even accomplish what
we have so far yeah I think so too cuz
in drunk minecraft heavily even made one
house wait wait
I got it you did it oh man I want to see
it I want document it on camera film
we've got a house look we got something
I don't know yet maybe me is growing is
we got a house holy crap oh it's got a
door I know oh my god this is awesome
I'm gonna make a bed we're gonna sleep
together we're gonna cuddle when it's
called it's gonna be quick wait wood
plank any wood
I need whatever it takes to make a bed
I'm gonna make a bed I'm gonna make you
a bed it's gonna be the best bed yeah
back are you gonna make two beds or just
one I only have enough to make one right
now but there's gonna be two as soon as
there's enough iron to make two
all right I'm gonna gather some more
wood to get our furnace burning okay you
do that
you go yeah dad would your the best
would get it we're doing good you're the
number one would get her in my heart
we've actually accomplished a lot more
in like three episodes between two
different servers that I accomplished in
my first two playthroughs really I don't
know how and you guys didn't believe us
out there you guys didn't believe in us
I saw the doubt in your mind I was
working on building an oil refinery but
ooh it took a lot longer to get this far
wait how do you do an oil refinery uh
lots of tea metal okay I would have
guessed that but I'm not iron I'm gonna
the recipes in there if you look at your
crafting table there's a recipe for it
geez there's a lot of stuff in there but
I didn't look at any of it I didn't like
look at it you expect me to look at it
uh yes oh okay geez I'm trying to get
this or it's really inconvenient because
the way like tosses it around and I have
to go back and come up again to get the
a I know it's not a smooth system okay
I'm just gonna put the iron in there for
now because iron is what we need we we
can get the other stuff later but I
really want to focusing on iron yeah we
get the bed we will spawn here every
time we die will spawn our house and
good timing too because it's almost
night these douchey dinos need to get
I'd forgot that there we even weren't
dinos in this game we haven't seen it at
this house just a little one there's the
little itty bitty ones that sank
Phyllida Neil us dead and have you seen
the t-rex yet yes I saw it I saw it
drinking water oh that's right you did
see what I did and you saw it up closing
it with eight newer what it did eat my
butt may your face hit your butt through
your face that's how much it ate you it
was it was painful I bet uh I have a bed
Wow my there did you hear that
I have bad
man I'm like Lady Godiva with the singer
lady MacGyver who's a good singer I
don't know like Lady Godiva Queen
stripping off in the Moody bong Madame
with you boo remark I'm gonna go gulab
Julie there's no dodgy copyrighted song
I'm on a dime we sued everyone we're all
good okay
new order sued nude nude sued we're
gonna be super easy to learn in the nude
yeah and then we're gonna have no food
and then we're gonna code we're gonna go
get some more wood and then we're gonna
get in the boot and sleep together in
the nude yeah yeah is it I don't even
know how long I've been recording this
one I got no timers going on I don't
know why there cuz I'm not stop
recording yet alright it's night let's
cuddle up in the bed and end the episode
there all right I'm going to put it no
no no no no oh
very booth toaster oh not very good do
you build our beds yet I built one bed
hang on I'll get the other bed yeah
all right you can't place it though I've
got to place it otherwise it won't Cal
that's right okay that makes sense
okay so there's just enough to make
another bed actually just for safety
I'll put the ingredients to make the bed
in the table okay you can pick it up and
then make it okay it's alright the
ironing it's there and the wood planks
are there just make a bed I don't want
any good washy maybe gay baby douchey to
us I don't want any of that just want to
make a bed and go to bed
have a good night's sleep get up and
kill some guys craft yes got it bad you
got a bad get in here before something
bad happens
alright what bad could possibly happen
and I would take me to walk to the door
yeah what horrible things could possibly
happen to us I have expected to get
gunned down I'm not gonna lie
what's in this PV maybe uh maybe maybe
put your bed down now yeah bed - ah
let's go - nappy-nap alright I picked up
the bed Oh tough you don't go through
the head you can actually sleep what
what are you talking about
sleeping them bad we can't just leave it
shut up i'ma sleeping this bad hang on
all right yeah yeah oh I got ya
yeah you're like a you're like a hermit
crab with the baddest your heads going
alright this is romantic enough okay so
thank you all so much for watching all
the doubters out there how dare you not
believe in us and our ability to play
games also we're sorry we're so sorry
for everything are you have to lizard in
this bowl so anyway thanks again
everybody for watching where to play one
more episode so thanks again thank you
wait for being here also thank you and
as always we'll see you in the next
video bye bye see you guys
we're here naughty - Popeye today